okay bad base it is your boy
psychobabble and we're back playing the
most depressing game of all time yes
this game is very depressing yes
there isn't a lot of talking music and
you're gonna [ __ ] take it down a
little bit oh my god I just make a
little smooth you know just like in a
little smooth okay okay all right let's
go back with you hello sir
where we going oh [ __ ] what is that chef
oh [ __ ] I say that mission yeah [ __ ]
run no you're not my dad so get away
from me yeah way to turn like a [ __ ]
light I was like Erica
ah [ __ ] I'm getting all [ __ ] up
that's just [ __ ] up I'm trying to
[ __ ] jump wait is this the run okay
yeah all right all right all right just
making sure it's been a long time
everybody sir yes sir
as the last time I listened
come on me the [ __ ] up here that doors
open hey little [ __ ]
alright okay I'm coming I got I'm trying
to make it quick but you keep on talking
hello sir holy [ __ ] they're talking lot
no yeah yes [ __ ] [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] he's got one oh [ __ ]
Wow all right [ __ ]
hello sir hello that's not good dark in
here that's all I gotta say
holy [ __ ] I [ __ ] hear them Holly [ __ ]
your [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ] it
yes stupid [ __ ]
90 second you stupid [ __ ] stupid [ __ ]
that's it again for banister if that's
okay huh
med kit yeah [ __ ] yeah is it okay
save the [ __ ] is talking like that
but I was popped his ass [ __ ] hate
this what the [ __ ] are you said on you
down oh yes you can only do when you're
like [ __ ] dying that computer on that
that's right
all right let's see here I hear someone
[ __ ] talking and they're talking I
don't need as an arrow all that talking
I don't need it [ __ ] here shut oh man
okay I'd like slowing luggage okay holy
[ __ ]
yes step add [ __ ] if I could stupid
[ __ ] anyway well since I played this
game I can't say that I missed her what
the [ __ ] did I just make a giant [ __ ]
loop this is a giant [ __ ] loop some
of those men should not have dropped
down here that's it that was thing I've
ever heard so what you have murder me I
don't know and frankly I don't want to
find out there you go [ __ ] it back up
here again oh yeah my [ __ ] comrades
shooting like crazy
okay yes say yes that's [ __ ] filthy
out here there we go yeah my god
[Music]
well I don't you could [ __ ] its sniping
like that
I hear him some with popping caps over
there oh [ __ ] Jase s remember that door
Sammy [ __ ] it's so Sidious picture sleep
[ __ ] shred this is like you say China
hun [ __ ] parking in Philly that's oh
this is so I gotta say
thank 15 minutes that's luck anymore
[ __ ] ammo okay I think this is where
it went bad last time see that a [ __ ]
hammer back here now it's time I got
left
a lot of [ __ ] the same huh
yeah sorry funny how's that beans
I got beans in there can I get back
there
can I just a bit no I guess not
oh I guess I could shop over uh-huh is
that a real thing Mike suck my dick here
no no okay get there here right here
okay get up here what's a chaos' I
understand now I like her
I guess it's the alarm but when I first
went off I think I say [ __ ] sobbing
oh no I [ __ ] got me okay well don't
go that way it's a [ __ ] dead end
says this get ready to [ __ ] fight I
guess [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] suck a dick okay except I
guess turn out the [ __ ] light you
guys a salad so I guess
now it's [ __ ] barking yeah
where's the other one
where's the other one
okay I guess that's it then you hit get
there someday okay cuz they can go that
way
is that the way I don't know I don't say
really have no [ __ ] idea
guess I gotta go this way [ __ ] call
down here that's all I gotta say
radiation [ __ ] a [ __ ] freezing I
just hate to go all the way around
I guess out that huh no I didn't make it
to you there I guess I have to jump
across right yeah I get it over there
but okay right now thank you
there we go oh my god that took like ten
years
oh all right
it says try saving [ __ ] is [ __ ]
if they show us was the GAO holy [ __ ]
that killed him
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] you tell him okay
that made it easy a lot of talking
phones here like hell I got to get back
so you see yeah that way I guess it's
[ __ ] gnarly okay where do I go though
over here alright I guess I'm not gone
that way
the [ __ ] is that I don't know what the
[ __ ] that is like babies
oh [ __ ] where do they come in from okay
scary here's a silencer I think I got a
lot more cops than I am all right he
says dry over there
sucks and supposed to mean I'm trying to
[ __ ] dry
and then [ __ ] hey over there that it's
it's [ __ ] disgusting
okay gone that way can't do that
I got here yet yeah I think I can but
that's up to you guys I mean I do get
out there [ __ ] is that
okay so really feel like I should be
able to go around here or something I
think second floor my Canada I think it
isn't oh my god okay Peck over there are
you shutting it that way
that's got it what the [ __ ] I'm supposed
to do anyone now yeah that's fine
there's got to be a [ __ ] diary huh
gonna pause and say you have to go
around to meet up with Barbie on the
hotel the [ __ ] is that without [ __ ]
house help
okay oh thank you up here what the [ __ ]
okay
[ __ ] trap destroy those [ __ ]
alright that's it now come on that's
[ __ ] disgusting
it gets gross - every time does anyone
know
so now is this [ __ ] disgusting in
here I need some [ __ ] paintin here
befe okay going up here
oh hello Samantha oh hello Joe about
that alright let's go over here okay any
[ __ ] in here any [ __ ] in here and
I'll bet his hair okay it's fine
hello sir thank ya thank ya I better
take a nap how am I taking that like it
so here's what that one [ __ ] is that I
try to go down this uh hello you're
gonna [ __ ] suck no no I'm a chimp tell
it shut alright we're [ __ ] brave did
so state machine gun for like Musa
I got nothing save that okay let the
courtyard okay sound yeah brother
[ __ ] no I don't hear anything
where the [ __ ] you mean I take the right
they're [ __ ] [ __ ]
you still taking that time holy [ __ ]
[ __ ] Dex on a ballsack
like some r-mo sorry
sir
I get the second in here brother
look [ __ ] there we go this is [ __ ]
unprofessional
[ __ ] running oh [ __ ]
he got a [ __ ] cop
thank you got me oh [ __ ]
can I get the [ __ ] out of here
wow that sucking bad the [ __ ] out of
here I can't abandon him what the [ __ ]
okay I guess we're doing this
okay leave and easily this is [ __ ]
hammer it is your [ __ ] he can use his
[ __ ] mouth
again you've gone out to him ah [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah get that [ __ ] yes oh my god